This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Back in 2011, a 13-year-old girl posted a music video on YouTube. It sat there for about a month without getting much notice. But then, something totally unexpected happened. The girl's name was Rebecca Black, and the song she was singing in the video was called Friday. More and more people started watching it, leaving comments and sharing it. The song went viral.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2011年，一位13岁的女孩在YouTube上发布了一段音乐视频。视频发布后大约一个月里，并没有引起太多关注。但随后，一件完全出乎意料的事情发生了。这个女孩名叫瑞贝卡·布莱克，她在视频中演唱的歌曲叫《Friday》。越来越多的人开始观看、评论并分享这首歌。这首歌火了。
Friday became the most watched YouTube video of 2011 with 167 million views. Plenty of people watched the video to make fun of it, perhaps not knowing or caring that Rebecca Black was only 13 years old. But a decade later, she's gotten the last laugh with the new remix of the song. That version, it's also gone viral, with millions of views in the first few days after it's released. This week on Hidden Brain, what makes certain songs, memes, and even social movements go viral? We look at why they spread and how social contagion can be harnessed to build a better world.
《Friday》成为了2011年YouTube上观看次数最多的视频，播放量达到1.67亿次。很多人观看这个视频是为了嘲笑它，或许他们并不知道，也不在乎瑞贝卡·布莱克当时只有13岁。但十年后，她凭借这首歌的新混音版笑到了最后。那个版本也火了，发布后的头几天就有数百万次的观看量。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨是什么让某些歌曲、模因甚至社会运动走红？我们将研究它们传播的原因，以及如何利用社会传染来构建一个更美好的世界。
How is it some social movements take off and spread, while others find themselves stuck? Why do some companies soar and become household names while others flame out? Can you predict success and failure? Or is it all a matter of luck? These are questions that have long fascinated Damon Centola. He's a sociologist at the University of Pennsylvania and the author of the book, Change. Damon Centola, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me.
为什么有些社会运动能够兴起并传播，而另一些却陷入停滞？为什么有些公司能够腾飞并家喻户晓，而另一些却昙花一现？你能预测成功与失败吗？还是说这纯粹是运气问题？这些问题长期以来一直让达蒙·森托拉着迷。他是宾夕法尼亚大学的社会学家，也是《变革》一书的作者。达蒙·森托拉，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我。
I want to start with one model of how something can spread very, very rapidly. In late 2019, Damon, a few people got infected with the COVID-19 virus in Wuhan, the Chinese city. Painted picture for me of how a virus can go from infecting a small number of people in one Chinese city to a global pandemic. Yeah, the way that virus is typically spread is through social contact. So that means that a few people in Wuhan will infect their friends and neighbors, the people they interact with directly.
我想从一个关于事物如何非常、非常迅速传播的模型开始谈起。2019年底，达蒙，中国武汉有几个人感染了新冠病毒。请为我描绘一下，一种病毒是如何从中国一个城市里的少数感染者演变成全球大流行的。是的，病毒通常是通过社会接触传播的。这意味着武汉的几个人会感染他们的朋友和邻居，也就是他们直接互动的人。
But it also means that if any one of those people gets onto an airplane and travels, say, to Tel Aviv or to Berlin, then that infected person can infect the people around them on the airplane just by mere proximity. And then obviously those people when they get off the plane will infect their friends and neighbors and so forth. And if those people get on an airplane,
但这同时也意味着，如果其中任何一个人坐上飞机去往，比如说特拉维夫或柏林，那么这个感染者仅仅通过近距离接触，就能感染飞机上周围的人。显然，当这些人下飞机后，他们又会感染他们的朋友和邻居，以此类推。如果这些人又坐上了飞机，
then of course they spread to a new part of the world. And so when we think about how this spreading process grows and how it spreads from one town to the globe, we really can imagine it as a series of firework explosions where one infected community basically infects everyone that they come in contact with. And then all of those people becomes for the center of their own fireworks explosions.
那么他们当然会将病毒传播到世界的新地方。因此，当我们思考这个传播过程是如何增长，以及它是如何从一个城镇扩散到全球时，我们真的可以把它想象成一系列烟花爆炸，一个受感染的社区基本上会感染他们接触到的每一个人。然后，所有这些人又会成为他们各自烟花爆炸的中心。
And what you get is this cascading series of fireworks that very quickly through rapid communication and transportation networks spread around the world. So what if your central contentions is that the way people are connected to each other, their social networks, influence how things spread or how they fail to spread. But let's just drill down our second deeper. Let's look at the social networks that allow a virus to spread exponentially.
于是你得到的是一系列连锁的烟花，通过快速的通信和交通网络，非常迅速地传播到世界各地。那么，如果你的核心论点是人们相互连接的方式，即他们的社交网络，影响了事物传播或无法传播的方式。但让我们深入探讨一下。让我们看看那些让病毒呈指数级传播的社交网络。
Let's say I'm at an airport, you're at an airport, we're sitting next to each other at a gate waiting for our flights, we don't know each other, we don't talk to one another, but this chance meeting allows a virus to leap between us. So for this network, transmitting the virus requires very brief contact between us, almost like a glancing connection, right? Yeah, that's exactly right. And in many ways, we think about other kinds of contagions that way too. When we think about the spread of information, if you're sitting next to me at an airport
假设我在机场，你在机场，我们坐在登机口的旁边等待航班，我们互不相识，也不交谈，但这次偶然的相遇让病毒在我们之间跳跃。所以对于这个网络来说，传播病毒需要我们之间非常短暂的接触，几乎就像一次擦肩而过的连接，对吧？是的，完全正确。在很多方面，我们也以同样的方式看待其他类型的传染。当我们思考信息的传播时，如果你在机场坐在我旁边，
and you tell me about a great new NPR show or a great new app that I can download, that I may do that and I can tell someone else that once I get home, and that's exactly how diseases spread as well. And so we can think about this epidemiological model, the spread of diseases as a metaphor or as an underlying guide for thinking about all kinds of spreading processes and how just simple contact with a stranger can transmit really anything around the world. So, it's very appealing to think that most things spread like viruses. You know, so you have the example of the COVID-19 virus or a song like Friday and it's easy
你告诉我一个很棒的NPR新节目或者一个我可以下载的很棒的新应用程序，我可能会这样做，等我回家后我也可以告诉别人，这正是疾病传播的方式。因此，我们可以将这种流行病学模型，即疾病的传播，视为思考所有传播过程的隐喻或潜在指南，以及仅仅与陌生人的简单接触是如何将任何东西传播到世界各地的。所以，认为大多数事物像病毒一样传播是非常有吸引力的。你知道，你有新冠病毒或像《Friday》这样的歌曲作为例子，很容易
to think that maybe everything spreads this way. Can you talk for a moment about how this fairly simple model of how things spread? How that model in some ways has, you know, if you will, gone viral? So the notion of influencers, which are highly connected people that we're all familiar with on social media sites like Instagram and Facebook and Twitter. And we tend to think of these influencers as the key to spreading any kind of innovation idea or social change process.
让人认为也许一切都是这样传播的。你能谈谈这种相当简单的传播模型吗？这个模型在某些方面是如何，如果你愿意的话，变得“病毒式传播”的？比如网红的概念，也就是我们在Instagram、Facebook和Twitter等社交媒体网站上都很熟悉的那些高连接度的人。我们倾向于认为这些网红是传播任何创新理念或社会变革过程的关键。
And that comes from viral thinking because if one person who interacts with a lot of other people gets COVID-19, then that person is gonna be a super spreader for the virus. So this idea that a highly connected person can be very effective for spreading something to lots of other people and therefore kind of set off an epidemic all by themselves, is an intuition that sits underneath viral marketing campaigns and the whole sort of
这源于病毒式思维，因为如果一个与许多其他人互动的人感染了新冠病毒，那么这个人就会成为该病毒的超级传播者。因此，这种认为一个高连接度的人可以非常有效地将某事物传播给许多其他人，从而独自引发一场流行病的想法，是潜藏在病毒式营销活动和整个那种
influencer marketing approach. And so for nearly a century actually, the assumption has been that everything spreads just like a virus does. Yeah, and I feel like you hear this narrative very often in the news. You cite the example of Oprah Winfrey sharing word in April 2009 about a new social media platform called Twitter. Listen to the state about that moment. Hi, it's Friday Live and I'm on Twitter for the first time. City next to me is Evan Williams, the co-founder of Twitter.
网红营销方法背后的直觉。事实上，近一个世纪以来，人们一直假设一切事物的传播方式都像病毒一样。是的，我觉得你在新闻中经常听到这种叙述。你引用了奥普拉·温弗瑞在2009年4月分享关于一个名为Twitter的新社交媒体平台的消息为例。听听关于那一刻的陈述。嗨，这是周五直播，我第一次上Twitter。坐在我旁边的是Twitter的联合创始人埃文·威廉姆斯。
Can you believe all this tweedly-d stuff going on? Hi. How did it come to life? How did it come to life? So, Damon, what is the conventional story of how Oprah's first tweet produced exponential growth of the Twitter platform? It's exactly what you would imagine,
你能相信所有这些推特乱七八糟的事情吗？嗨。它是怎么诞生的？它是怎么诞生的？那么，达蒙，关于奥普拉的第一条推文如何促成Twitter平台指数级增长的传统故事是什么？这正是你所想象的那样，
which is Twitter wasn't growing very fast. And then what we see in the timeline after and around Oprah's adoption of Twitter is that Twitter has by, I think, the end of that month, 28 million users. And so the natural thing to do or the intuitive justification or rationale for what we see happening is to say, oh, that company was successful know, that company was successful in getting, you know, a high profile influencer to endorse their product, and as a result, their product was then adopted by a lot of people. So I want to spend a moment defining a couple of terms that are going to come up repeatedly in the conversation.
那就是Twitter之前增长得并不快。而在奥普拉采用Twitter之后及期间的时间线上，我们看到Twitter在那个月底，我想，拥有了2800万用户。所以，最自然的做法，或者对我们所见现象的直观辩护或理由，就是说，哦，那家公司成功了，你知道，那家公司成功地让一位高知名度的网红代言了他们的产品，结果，他们的产品随后被很多人采用了。所以我想花点时间定义几个在对话中会反复出现的术语。
Let's return to that moment in the airport. Sociologists call the connection that you and I had at the gate, a weak tie. What are weak ties, Damon? And can you give me some other examples of weak ties? Sure. I should mention that the term weak ties and that's complement strong tie come from the sociologist Mark Granoveter, who is personally one of my intellectual heroes. He defined these terms back in 1973.
让我们回到机场的那一刻。社会学家将你我在登机口的连接称为“弱关系”。什么是弱关系，达蒙？你能给我举一些弱关系的其他例子吗？当然。我应该提到，“弱关系”及其补充词“强关系”这两个术语来自社会学家马克·格兰诺维特，他是我个人的偶像之一。他在1973年定义了这些术语。
Now the glancing contact that happens in the airport, Grant have had referred to as a weektie because if you and I are sitting next to each other in an airport we're not likely to know each other's friends or family we're not likely to even ever meet again. But that connection can act as an important in some senses like vital transmission point for a piece of information from your community to my community. And so what Mark did that was so interesting is notice that these week ties that don't play a huge role in how we conceptualize or think about our social networks are largely invisible, but nevertheless,
机场里发生的擦肩而过的接触，格兰诺维特称之为弱关系，因为如果你我在机场坐在一起，我们不太可能认识对方的朋友或家人，我们甚至可能永远不会再见面。但这种连接可以作为一种重要的，在某种意义上像关键传播点一样，将信息从你的社区传送到我的社区。所以马克所做的非常有趣的事情是注意到，这些在我们的社交网络概念化或思考方式中并不起很大作用的弱关系，在很大程度上是隐形的，但尽管如此，
they're playing this important role for the transmission of ideas and information and diseases, of course, from communities, community, and across nations and ultimately across the world. So Mark Ranoveder's influential paper was called The Strength of Weekties. And besides being a very catchy title, it was about this very important idea that weekties in some ways can spur things
它们在思想、信息以及疾病从社区到社区、跨越国家并最终跨越世界的传播中发挥着重要作用。所以马克·格兰诺维特那篇有影响力的论文题目是《弱关系的力量》。除了是一个非常吸引人的标题外，它还关乎这个非常重要的观点，即弱关系在某些方面可以刺激事物
to travel very quickly and spread very fast. Can you give me some examples of the strength of weekties in everyday life? Yeah, Mark's actually an initial example was looking at how people find out about jobs. And of course when you're looking for a job and you're an employee, you talk to your friends, you talk to your family, you sort of try to source out what available options there are in what you think of as your network. But often time, everyone in your community knows about the same openings because everyone
传播得非常快。你能给我举一些日常生活中弱关系力量的例子吗？是的，马克最初的例子是观察人们如何找到工作。当然，当你作为一名员工在找工作时，你会和朋友交谈，和家人交谈，你会试图在你认为的网络中寻找可用的选择。但通常情况下，你社区里的每个人都知道同样的空缺，因为每个人
in your community has the same friends and they know the same people. And so it's very hard to learn about a new job opening or a new opportunity from the people that you already know. And so what Mark realized was that when people learn about new opportunities, it's often from these glancing contacts where you're just talking casually in the airport. Someone mentions, oh, I think that this division at Microsoft is hiring. Or I heard that actually there's a new Amazon's opening up a new branch in this area, and that might be interesting to you, that your friends and family might not know about,
在你的社区里都有同样的朋友，他们认识同样的人。所以很难从你已经认识的人那里了解到新的工作机会。因此，马克意识到，当人们了解到新的机会时，往往是通过那些擦肩而过的接触，比如你在机场随意交谈时。有人提到，哦，我想微软的这个部门正在招聘。或者我听说亚马逊在这个地区开设了一个新分支机构，这可能对你很有趣，而你的朋友和家人可能不知道，
but that is, of course, incredibly relevant for you doing a job search. And so these weak ties are incredibly effective, and you can think of that as efficient for information transmission. You know, as new information comes up, it's very easy for that to spread across these sort of casual contexts. that as efficient for information transmission, as new information comes up, it's very easy for that to spread across these sort of casual contacts. You started to see evidence that this model of how things spread can have serious problems.
但这当然对你的求职非常重要。所以这些弱关系非常有效，你可以认为这对于信息传播是高效的。你知道，当新信息出现时，它很容易在这些随意的环境中传播。对于信息传播是高效的，当新信息出现时，它很容易在这些随意的接触中传播。你开始看到证据表明，这种事物传播的模型可能存在严重问题。
And I want to point to a couple of moments of insight that you say that you had. You grew up in a Quaker community where you were part of a lot of marches for social justice, but you noticed that your classmates at school didn't always care about the same issues. How did they speak to the ability or the inability of weak ties to spread ideas?
我想指出你提到的几个让你产生洞察的时刻。你在一个贵格会社区长大，参加过很多社会正义游行，但你注意到学校里的同学并不总是关心同样的问题。他们是如何体现弱关系传播思想的能力或无能的？
Yeah, well what I noticed was that across different groups or communities, it wasn't just they didn't care about them, they just didn't even know about them, there wasn't like engagement, and if someone were to talk about an issue like what are conservation or like fair gender practices in the workplace, at least in my middle school, it wasn't something that people understood. And so you could announce that there's some march or rally or you could talk about the importance of these issues, but it would largely fall on deaf ears, because the community of classmates and the way that people talked about topics didn't really engage
是的，我注意到在不同的群体或社区中，并不是他们不关心这些问题，而是他们甚至根本不知道这些问题，没有那种参与感。如果有人谈论像水资源保护或工作场所公平性别实践这样的问题，至少在我读初中时，这不是人们能理解的东西。所以你可以宣布有某种游行或集会，或者你可以谈论这些问题的重要性，但基本上会充耳不闻，因为同学群体以及人们谈论话题的方式并没有真正参与
with or understand those ideas. If everything spreads like a virus, how is it some ideas don't leap from group to group? Damon was exposed to ideas about social justice at home, so why didn't they leap through him to his classmates? Why didn't he, if you will, infect them with those concepts? Damon also noticed something else. Over time, some ideas that were popular in one community did spread to others. But the way this happened did not look anything like a virus. Sometimes it took decades for those ideas to spread. Take, for example, the support for renewable energy or gay rights.
或理解那些想法。如果一切都像病毒一样传播，为什么有些想法不能在群体之间跳跃？达蒙在家里接触到了社会正义的思想，那么为什么它们没有通过他跳跃到他的同学身上？为什么他没有，如果你愿意的话，用这些概念感染他们？达蒙还注意到了另一件事。随着时间的推移，一些在一个社区中流行的想法确实传播到了其他社区。但这种发生的方式看起来一点也不像病毒。有时这些想法需要几十年才能传播开来。以对可再生能源或同性恋权利的支持为例。
I noticed that some of those ideas actually had caught on, by the time I started college, a lot of people in the mainstream were talking about some of these issues in a sort of a regular everyday way. There were normal topics to think about. One of the issues in a sort of a regular everyday way. There were normal topics to think about. One of the most striking examples was like the organic foods movement, which was a very marginal sort of fringe idea in the early 1980s that you would go to a grocery store
我注意到其中一些想法确实流行起来了，到我上大学时，主流社会中的许多人都在以一种常规的、日常的方式谈论其中一些问题。它们是思考的正常话题。其中一个以一种常规的、日常的方式谈论的问题。最引人注目的例子之一是像有机食品运动，这在20世纪80年代初是一个非常边缘的想法，你会去杂货店
and only buy organic whole grain foods and have to go to a bulk bin to get it. And a decade later, it was normal for grocery stores to have an aisle that was reserved for what they called health food. And of course, whole foods came along. And so, the influence of these peripheral movements on the mainstream was surprisingly effective for some things, but never landed for others. Right? Movements like water conservation, which was also a big one among some of the activists that
只买有机全谷物食品，并且必须去散装箱购买。十年后，杂货店有一个专门留给他们所谓的“健康食品”的过道是很正常的。当然，全食超市也随之出现了。因此，这些边缘运动对主流的影响在某些方面出奇地有效，但对另一些方面却从未奏效。对吧？像水资源保护这样的运动，在一些我成长过程中认识的活动家中也是一个大议题，
I knew growing up, never really caught on in the mainstream. The US and still hasn't. And so, the question that was raised for me, which I think is the really important question, is why? You know, is it just random or is there some underlying sort of scientific explanation for the success of some movements in the failure of others? The Negro passengers on the city bus lines of Montgomery have been humiliated, intimidated, face threats on this bus line.
从未真正在主流中流行起来。在美国至今也没有。所以，对我提出的问题，我认为这是真正重要的问题，是为什么？你知道，这只是随机的，还是说这些运动的成功与失败背后有某种潜在的科学解释？蒙哥马利市公交线路上的黑人乘客在这个公交线路上受到了羞辱、恐吓，面临威胁。
As a young scholar, you started to examine the growth and success of the civil rights movement, and you started to see problems with the conventional story of viral spread of how that movement took off. Can you describe that insight to me using the examples of Rosa Parks and a woman named Claudette COVID? Yeah, the civil rights movement became one of the most interesting areas for me to study because of how the story is told that with the Montgomery bus boycott, Rosa Parks refused to move to the back of the bus. And she was arrested. And in many senses, this becomes a kind of galvanizing moment for the civil rights movement.
作为一名年轻的学者，你开始研究民权运动的增长和成功，你开始看到关于该运动如何兴起的病毒式传播的传统故事存在问题。你能用罗莎·帕克斯和一位名叫克劳黛特·科尔文的女性的例子向我描述这种洞察吗？是的，民权运动成为我研究中最有趣的领域之一，因为这个故事的讲述方式是，随着蒙哥马利公交车抵制运动，罗莎·帕克斯拒绝移动到公交车后部。她被捕了。在很多意义上，这成为了民权运动的一个激励时刻。
Just the other day, one of the fine citizens of our community, Mrs. Rosa Parks, was arrested because she refused to give up her seat for a white passenger. And so the story that's told, which is analogous in many ways to kind of the sort of story of Twitter growing because of its moment on Oprah, the story that's told is there's one person stands up and then a movement follows and then the whole system of racial segregation collapses. But the truth of it is that lots you know, lots and lots of women stood up
就在前几天，我们社区的一位优秀公民，罗莎·帕克斯夫人，因为拒绝为白人乘客让座而被捕。所以讲述的故事，在很多方面类似于Twitter因为奥普拉的时刻而增长的故事，讲述的故事是一个人站了出来，然后一场运动随之而来，然后整个种族隔离制度就崩溃了。但事实是，很多人，你知道，很多很多女性都站出来
intentionally against racial segregation on public buses. Claudette Colvin is one of them, but there are dozens of others of women who, you know, took a stand against that racial injustice, but they were arrested and nothing much came of it. It is a repeat I told him, I paid my fair and it's my constitution right to see here. Claudette Colvin was 15 years old when she was arrested and dragged off a bus in handcuffs in Montgomery, Alabama. This happened nine months before Rosa Parks did exactly the same thing.
故意反对公共汽车上的种族隔离。克劳黛特·科尔文就是其中之一，但还有几十位女性，你知道，对那种种族不公正采取了立场，但她们被捕了，并没有发生什么大事。这是一个重复，我告诉他，我付了车费，我有宪法权利坐在这里。克劳黛特·科尔文在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利被捕并戴上手铐拖下公交车时只有15岁。这发生在罗莎·帕克斯做同样事情的九个月前。
When the news reporters asked me why didn't I get up, I said history had me glue to the seat. I said, felt as though, how are you talking to me hand, but pushing me down on one shoulder and so jr. Truth hand, but pushing me down on another shoulder. When we come back, how social networks explain the difference between the impact of Rosa Parks and the impact of Claudette Colvin. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
当新闻记者问我为什么不起来时，我说历史让我粘在了座位上。我说，感觉好像，你怎么跟我说话，一只手推着我的一边肩膀，另一只手推着我的另一边肩膀。当我们回来时，社交网络如何解释罗莎·帕克斯的影响力和克劳黛特·科尔文的影响力之间的差异。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Damon Santola is a sociologist at the University of Pennsylvania. He studies how change unfolds within communities, within companies, within countries. He argues that the conventional models we have about virality don't describe why one social movement takes off while it's second stalls. Damon, you draw a very important distinction in your book between what you call simple contagion and complex contagion. What do you mean by those terms? Well, if we think of social change as a contagion process, some people accept an idea and then the people they come in contact with are accepted and so forth, it's natural to think of that
达蒙·森托拉是宾夕法尼亚大学的社会学家。他研究变革如何在社区、公司、国家内部展开。他认为，我们关于病毒式传播的传统模型并不能解释为什么一场社会运动会兴起，而另一场却停滞不前。达蒙，你在书中对你所谓的“简单传染”和“复杂传染”做了非常重要的区分。你所说的这些术语是什么意思？嗯，如果我们把社会变革看作一个传染过程，一些人接受了一个想法，然后他们接触到的人也接受了，以此类推，自然会想到
in a viral way, spreading just like a virus would. And that is really the notion of simple contagion, which is just about everyone that and infected or activated or excited person comes in contact with also becomes excited and activated. I'm here to join the people bringing attention to Lou Gehrig's disease by taking the ALS Ice Bucket Challenge. And so that's how a meme spreads, or that's how I sort of contagious news story spreads from person to person.
以病毒的方式，传播得就像病毒一样。这就是“简单传染”的概念，即每一个被感染、被激活或被兴奋的人接触到的每个人也都变得兴奋和被激活。我在这里加入那些通过参加ALS冰桶挑战来关注卢·格里克氏症的人们。这就是一个模因传播的方式，或者这就是一个传染性的新闻故事从一个人传到另一个人的方式。
And when we think about simple contagions, what we're really talking about is ideas that are familiar, products that we already really know, things that make sense to us intuitively. And so when we see a new one, it's not a lot of work, emotionally or cognitively, or any other way to just adopt it and pass it on. It just seems normal. Notice lots of ice. Don't cheese out.
当我们思考简单传染时，我们真正谈论的是我们熟悉的主意、我们已经真正了解的产品、那些在直觉上对我们有意义的事物。所以当我们看到一个新的时，在情感上、认知上或任何其他方面，采用它并传递它并不需要太多工作。它看起来很正常。注意大量的冰。别怂。
Complex contagions by contrast are the kinds of social change initiatives or the kinds of ideas or the kinds of products that we resist initially that aren't familiar that are weird or a little bit different. Just coming into contact with one person who's advocating for it or who has adopted it isn't enough to convince us that we should do it too. we should do it too. A great example of this is something like, you know, joining a protest march, where you might join a protest march because it's a good idea and you're on board with the movement. But if you have no idea about the movement,
相比之下，复杂传染是那种我们最初会抵制、不熟悉、奇怪或有点不同的社会变革倡议、想法或产品。仅仅接触到一个倡导它或已经采用它的人，不足以说服我们也应该这样做。一个很好的例子是，你知道，参加抗议游行，你可能会因为这是一个好主意并且你支持这场运动而参加抗议游行。但如果你对这场运动一无所知，
you're not oriented to it at all, you don't really care about it. And if there's the possibility of being arrested or the possibility of police retaliation, there's some risk involved with that choice. And so just because someone you know is doing it doesn't mean you're going to be convinced that you should do it too. And this is the sort of the big difference between a simple contagion
你根本没有被引导，你并不真正关心它。如果存在被捕的可能性或警察报复的可能性，那么这个选择就涉及一些风险。所以仅仅因为你认识的人在做这件事，并不意味着你会被说服你也应该这样做。这就是简单传染和复杂传染之间的巨大区别。
and a complex contagion. For a simple contagion to spread, all it takes is contact with one person. You're just basically finding out about it. You found out about the new meme, and you can watch it and spread it. But for a complex contagion, you need to be convinced. One of the hallmarks of complex contagions is they require people to accept certain costs. If you want people to change their behavior in some important way, you want them to recycle more or drive more slowly or practice safe sex, these changes can involve personal
对于简单传染的传播，只需要与一个人接触。你基本上只是发现了它。你发现了新的模因，你可以观看并传播它。但对于复杂传染，你需要被说服。复杂传染的标志之一是它们要求人们接受一定的成本。如果你想让人们以某种重要的方式改变他们的行为，你想让他们多回收利用、开车慢一点或进行安全性行为，这些改变可能涉及个人
costs. They're not like sharing a video of someone doing the ice bucket challenge or passing on the Friday song, which has almost zero costs. Why would it be that the social networks that prompt people to share cat videos are different from the social networks that can get someone out on the street to protest racial injustice. To explain, Damon Sites an example from 2013, where the Human Rights Campaign launched an initiative on Facebook to build support for same-sex marriage. Because the Supreme Court was hearing this case about same-sex marriage. And the initiative was to have people change their profile photo to an equal
成本。它们不像分享某人做冰桶挑战的视频或传递《Friday》这首歌，后者几乎零成本。为什么促使人们分享猫咪视频的社交网络与能让某人走上街头抗议种族不公正的社交网络不同？为了解释，达蒙引用了2013年的一个例子，当时人权运动组织在Facebook上发起了一项倡议，以建立对同性婚姻的支持。因为最高法院正在审理这个关于同性婚姻的案件。该倡议是让人们将他们的个人资料照片更改为粉红色和红色的等号，以表示对该运动的支持。然后我开始浏览我的动态，我简直不敢相信。它字面上就是一个红色的符号，一遍又一遍。大约24小时后，我们就知道我们真的有所发现了，它已经病毒式传播了。现在，这项倡议在不到一周的时间内传播到了近300万Facebook用户。所以这听起来像是病毒式传播的东西。但一些数据科学家和物理学家更仔细地观察了这些数据。
sign that was pink and red to show support for the movement. And then I started looking through my feet and I just couldn't believe it. It was literally just a red symbol over and over and over again. It was about 24 hours when we knew that we were really onto something that I had gone viral. Now this initiative spread to almost 3 million Facebook users in under a week. So that sounds like something that's viral. But some data scientists and physicists looked more closely at the data.
他们看到的是，这种社会传染的传播，这种支持同性婚姻的变革倡议，是一种复杂传染，尽管它传播得非常快。这种复杂传染的特征是，在人们从他们的邻居那里采用它之前，他们等待更多的邻居采用它。如果你想想你在Facebook上的生活，
And what they saw was that the spreading of this social contagion, this sort of change initiative to support SAMHSAG's marriage, was a complex contagion, even though it spread really fast. And the signature of this complex contagion was that before people adopted it from one of their neighbors, they waited for more of their neighbors to adopt it. And if you think about your life on Facebook,
你与许多不同的人相连。你知道，你可能会看到你的祖父母，你可能与你的父母、大学朋友、高中朋友、工作认识的人、邻居相连。所有这些人都在评估你的行为。所以采用某种有点争议的东西存在某种社会风险，或者
you're connected to lots of different people. You know, you may see your grandparents, you may be connected to your parents, your friends from college, your friends from high school, people you know from work, people from your neighborhood. And all of those people are, people from your neighborhood. And all of those people are sort of evaluating your behavior. So there's some sort of social risk on adopting something that's kind of controversial, or
可能不被这些人接受，或者你甚至可能冒着在你的社交媒体网站上引发争论的风险。所以人们所做的是，他们等到两、三个、四个、五个他们的联系人采用了。然后这给了他们足够的信心，认为这种新行为是合法的，然后人们所做的是，他们等到两、三个、四个、五个他们的联系人采用了，然后这给了他们足够的信心，认为这种新行为是合法的，然后他们也会采用。现在，那种你需要来自几个人的社会强化来说服你采用某事物的想法，意味着你需要能够从同伴那里产生一种强化压力的网络。如果我们记得当我们思考冠状病毒的传播时，它像烟花爆炸一样传播。所以一个人采用了并感染了许多人，然后那些人感染了许多其他人，而第一个人可能并不认识他们，以此类推。
may not be accepted by these people, or you may even run the risk of starting in a flame more, an argument on your social media site. And so what people did is they waited until two, three, four, five of their sort of context adopted. And then that gave them enough confidence that this new behavior was legitimate, and then people did is they waited until two, three, four, five of their sort of contacts adopted, and then that gave them enough confidence that this new behavior was legitimate and then they would adopt too. Now, that idea that you need social reinforcement
所以烟花爆炸中没有太多的冗余。它有巨大的覆盖范围，所以它可以非常快地传遍世界。但它没有那种来自人们采用并分享一个想法，并为之创造大量强化的社会说服力。你实际上在这里触及了几个非常重要的不同想法，我们
from several people to convince you to adopt something means that you need networks that create a kind of reinforcing pressure from peers. If we remember when we think about the spread of the coronavirus, it spread like a fireworks explosion. So one person adopted and infected lots of people, and then those people infected lots of other people that the first person may not know, and so on and so forth.
应该慢慢地拆解它们，达蒙。好的。你知道，你书的核心是一个非常重要的洞察。人们以任何重要方式改变行为的核心原因是他们看到周围的人在改变他们的行为。所以心理学家有时称之为社会证明。我上Facebook是因为其他人也在Facebook上。我在街上游行是因为我看到像我一样的人在街上游行。
And so a fireworks explosion doesn't have a lot of redundancy in it. It's got a ton of reach, and so it can get across the world really fast. But it doesn't have a lot of that kind of social convincement from people adopting and kind of sharing one idea with each other and creating a lot of reinforcement for it. You've actually touched on several different ideas here that are really important that we
如果你将这种洞察应用于变革科学，对我们来说真正的问题可能不是：我如何让这个人改变？而是：我如何向这个人展示他们周围的人正在改变？这在某种程度上是那个试图推动这种复杂传染的人的目标吗？是的，有两个目标。一个是，当然，让新的采用者对这个想法感到兴奋。做到这一点的一种方法是让他们的几个
should actually unpack somewhat slowly, Damon. Okay. You know, the core of your book is a very important insight. The central reason people change their behavior in any important way is because they see the people around them changing their behavior. So psychologists sometimes call the social proof. I get on Facebook because other people are on Facebook. I march on the streets because I see other people like me marching on the streets.
同伴在环境中采用，这为这个想法创造了可信度，使它看起来更被他们的朋友圈所接受，并且还可以产生关于加入的情感兴奋。但还有第二部分，那就是如果这个想法相当有争议，早期采用的人，如果他们看到没有其他人采用，最终可能会放弃。他们最终可能会说，好吧，这实际上不是我参与的好事，因为没有其他人支持它。所以与现有的采用者以及那些表现出对想法支持的人建立联系，能让人们保持参与，并维持对这个想法的成员资格。
If you apply that insight to the science of change, the real question to us might not be, how do I make this person change? But how can I show this person that the people around them are changing? Is that in some ways the goal of the person who's actually trying to drive this kind of complex contagion? Yeah, there are two goals. One is, of course, to have new adopters get excited about the idea. And one way to do that is to have several of their
所以如果你想想看，它实际上更像是一个渔网，而不是烟花表演。在渔网中，你有很多三角形连接着这些不同的社区和人，你知道，认识人，他们认识朋友的朋友，以此类推。这种冗余给了人们信心，认为这个想法是值得的，这个新行为是被接受的，然后允许他们与其他新的采用者协调，从而说服其他人采用，以此类推。所以你做了一个有趣的实验，测试了冗余在驱动行为方面的力量。在某种程度上，它比较了烟花形状的网络中发生的事情，我与三个人交谈，那三个人与另外三个人交谈，以此类推，与渔网示例进行了比较，在渔网中，我与其他人连接在一个网络中，并且我不断地一遍又一遍地从网络中的同一个人那里听到信息。你做了一个实验，试图
peers in context adopt, which creates credibility for the idea, makes it seem more accepted by their friendship group, and can also generate emotional excitement about getting on board. But there's a second part, which is that if the idea is fairly contentious, people who adopt early on, if they see that no one else has adopted, may wind up giving it up. They may wind up saying, well, this is actually not a good thing for me to be a part of, because no one else is supporting it. And so having connections to existing adopters and to people who are showing support for an idea keeps people engaged and it sort of sustains membership in the idea.
通过观察这两种不同的社交网络来推动健康干预。关于冗余与实际让人们改变行为的有效性之间的关系，你发现了什么？是的，当我做的时候，我创建了一个有大约150人的烟花爆炸网络，然后是一个有相同人数的类似网络，但每个人都连接成一个渔网。每个人都有机会知道他们将了解一种新的健康技术，然后我把这种健康技术放入每个网络中的一个人身上，然后想看看哪些联系人会去注册那种新的健康技术。哪种社交网络会触发行为改变？
So if you think about it, it's really more like a fishing net than a fireworks display. And so in a fishing net, you've got lots of triangles connecting these different neighborhoods and people, you know, no people, and they know their friends of friends and so forth. And that redundancy gives people confidence that the idea is worth wire that this new behavior is accepted and then allows them to coordinate with other new adopters to then convince other people to adopt and so on and so forth. So you ran an interesting experiment that sort of tested the power of redundancy in driving behavior. In some ways it sort of compared what happens in a network that is in the shape of fireworks where I'm talking to three people, those three people are talking to three other people and so on, versus a efficient next example where I'm connected in a network with other people and I'm constantly hearing from the same people in the network over and over again. You ran an experiment trying
是组织得像烟花表演那样，人们在不断扩大的链条中与他人连接，还是渔网，人们在闭环中连接？达蒙发现，尽管信息在组织得像渔网的网络中传播得较慢，但该网络中实际上有更多人改变了他们的行为。是的，我认为虽然在信息信号方面到达网络周围需要更长一点的时间。但采用的实际增长在这些渔网中传播得比在烟花网络中快得多、远得多。现在我做了六次同样的实验，得到了同样的结果，这意味着你可以得出一个非常强大的结论，那就是你可以得出一个强有力的科学主张，即通过在人群中构建通信网络，你可以改变人们采用新行为的可能性。所以，退后一步，从大局上看一眼。我们从谈论病毒以及病毒如何传播开始，我们展示了病毒
to drive a health intervention looking at these two different kinds of social networks. What did you find about the relationship between redundancy and the effectiveness of actually getting people to change their behavior? Yeah, well when I did, I created a fireworks explosion network with about 150 people on it, and then a similar network with the same number of people, but everyone was connected into a phishing net. And everyone was given the opportunity to know that they would learn about a new health technology, and then I put the health technology with one person into each network, and then wanted to just see if which of those contacts would go sign up for that new health technology. With social network, would trigger behavioral change?
通过这种弱关系网络传播。人们稍微认识对方。他们很快就有这些擦肩而过的接触。某事物可以从中国的一个城市一直传遍全球。然后我们看了这种其他类型的变革，它涉及更困难的，你知道，行为改变，人们实际上必须以某种重要方式改变他们的行为或态度或规范。为了做到这一点，他们通常需要强化，不仅来自一个人，而是来自多个与他们联系更紧密的人，也就是一种强关系网络。你提出，对于复杂传染，这实际上是我们大多数人在谈论变革时真正谈论的那种变革，你实际上需要这些强关系，而不是弱关系网络。当你观察像民权运动这样的事情时，你发现人们是通过弱关系还是强关系改变了他们的行为？是的，这是关于民权运动最引人注目的发现之一，所有的证据都支持强关系。这在当时是一个启示，因为理论都说社会变革
The one organized like a fireworks display where people are connected to others in an expanding chain, or the fishing net where people were connected in a closed loop. Damon found that although information spread more slowly in the network organized like a fishing net, more people in that network actually changed their behavior. Yeah, I think that although it took a little bit longer to reach around the network in terms of the informational signal. The actual growth of adoption spread much faster and much farther across these fishing
特别是民权运动，可以通过社交网络中的弱关系来解释，这些弱关系允许关于活动的信息传播到很远的地方。但事实证明，虽然信息传播得很远，但实际参与并没有，参与是通过聚集在一起的朋友的朋友传播的，他们可以提供
networks than across the fireworks network. Now I ran this same experiment six different times and I got the same result, which means you can draw a very powerful kind of conclusion, which is you can make a strong scientific claim that by structuring a communication network among a group of people which is you can make a strong scientific claim that by structuring a communication network among a group of people online, you can change people's likelihood of adopting a new behavior. So, just a step back and look at the big picture for a second. We started by talking about viruses and how viruses spread, and we showed that viruses
社会强化，可以降低参与的风险，并最终可以在新参与者之间产生强烈的社会传染，并将一场运动从网络边缘的一个集群发展到遍及全国。现在所有这些在某种程度上产生了一个难题，达蒙。如果人们在改变之前想看到其他人改变，合理的问题是，任何事情是如何改变的？因为是什么让球开始滚动？所以有些人可能会说，好吧，这就是名人或网红介入的地方。
spread through this network of weak ties. People know each other slightly. They have these glancing contacts very quickly. Something can go from a city in China to all the way around the planet. And then we looked at this other kind of change, which involves much more difficult, you know, behavioral change, where people actually have to change their behavior or their attitudes or their norms in some important way. And in order to do this, they often need reinforcement, not just from one, but from multiple people who are connected to them more closely, sort of a network of strong ties. And you make the case that for complex contagion, which is actually the kind of change that
这就是奥普拉介入的地方。如果一位名人公开支持某事，其他人会跟随。你在很多方面称这为一个神话。为什么名人在引发行为改变方面不是很有效？他们可能在引发意识方面有效，但为什么他们在引发这种复杂传染方面不是很有效？嗯，当你处理我们所说的网红时，你需要考虑两件事。一是，让网红在传播简单传染方面如此有效的原因是他们有很多很多的联系。但当谈到复杂传染时，想法
most of us are actually talking about when we talk about change, you actually need these strong ties rather than the network of weak ties. When you looked at something like the civil rights movement, did you find that people change their behavior through weak ties or through strong ties? Yeah, that was one of the most striking findings about the civil rights movement is that the evidence all works in favor of strong ties. And that was a revelation at the time because the theories had all said that social change
我们大多数人在谈论变革时，实际上需要的是这些强关系，而不是弱关系网络。当你研究民权运动这类事件时，你发现人们是通过弱关系还是强关系改变了他们的行为？是的，这是关于民权运动最引人注目的发现之一，所有证据都支持强关系的作用。这在当时是一个启示，因为之前的理论都认为社会变革
and in particular the civil rights movement would be explained by weak ties in social networks that would allow information about activities to spread far and wide. But it turned out that although the information spread far and wide actual participation didn't, participation spread through friends of friends who are clustered together who could provide
特别是民权运动，应该由社交网络中的弱关系来解释，因为弱关系能让有关活动的信息广泛传播。但事实证明，尽管信息传播得很广，但实际的参与度并没有，参与是通过聚集在一起的朋友的朋友传播的，他们可以提供
social reinforcement, who could reduce the risk of participation, and ultimately could generate a strong emotional contagion among new participants and grow a movement from a cluster in the periphery of the network to reach across the nation. Now all of this in some ways produces a puzzle dammit. If people want to see others change before they change, the reasonable question is, how does anything ever change? Because what gets the ball rolling? So some people might say, okay, that's where the celebrity or the influencer comes in.
社会强化，可以降低参与风险，并最终在新的参与者中产生强烈的群体情绪感染，从而将一场运动从网络边缘的一个集群扩展到全国。现在，这一切在某种程度上产生了一个难题。如果人们想看到别人改变后自己才改变，那么合理的问题是，事情怎么可能发生改变呢？因为是什么让事情开始的？所以有些人可能会说，好吧，这就是名人或网红发挥作用的地方。
That's where Oprah comes in. If a celebrity comes out in favor of something, others will follow. You call this a myth in many ways. Why are celebrities not very effective at sparking behavioral change? It might be effective at sparking awareness, but why are they not very effective at sparking this kind of complex contagion? Well, there are two things you need to think about when you're dealing with what we refer to as influencers. And one is that what makes influencers so effective for spreading simple contagions is they've got lots and lots of ties. But when it comes to complex contagious, again, ideas
这就是奥普拉发挥作用的地方。如果一位名人公开支持某件事，其他人就会效仿。你在很多方面称这为一个神话。为什么名人在引发行为改变方面不是很有效？他们可能在引发意识方面很有效，但为什么他们在引发这种复杂的传染方面却不是很有效呢？嗯，当你处理我们所说的网红时，你需要考虑两件事。一是让网红在传播简单传染方面如此有效的原因是他们拥有非常多的关系。但当涉及到复杂传染时，也就是想法
that are unfamiliar or ideas that maybe go against existing norms, the social influencer is highly observed. A lot of people are paying attention to their behavior, which means they're fairly careful about deciding what they're going to do and not do. Someone doesn't become highly connected by ignoring their social ties, they become highly connected by paying a lot of attention to what people expect of them. And this is true in entertainment, it's also true in business. And so what that means is that when people are evaluating
对于那些不熟悉的想法，或者可能违背现有规范的想法，社交影响者会受到高度关注。很多人都在密切注视他们的行为，这意味着他们在决定做什么和不做什么时相当谨慎。一个人不会通过忽视自己的社会关系而变得高度互联，他们之所以变得高度互联，是因为他们非常关注人们对他们的期望。这在娱乐界是如此，在商业界也是如此。这意味着，当人们在评估
which new ideas to take on, which new products to adopt, particularly products that are public, products that people talk about, they have to take into account how everyone around them is going to perceive that decision, which means that when it comes to complex contagions, all of the non-adoptors are actually forces against adoption. They're not just neutral. This is a crucial idea. Remember how we said the central goal in behavior change is to show people that those around them are changing? Turns out, the same thing goes for celebrities and influencers.
哪些新想法值得采纳，哪些新产品值得接受时，特别是那些公开的、人们会谈论的产品，他们必须考虑到周围的每一个人会如何看待这一决定。这意味着，当涉及到复杂的传染时，所有非采纳者实际上都是阻碍采纳的力量。他们不仅仅是中立的。这是一个至关重要的观点。还记得我们说过行为改变的核心目标是向人们展示他们周围的人正在改变吗？事实证明，名人和影响者也是如此。
They wait to see what their fans think. It may be counterintuitive, but if they don't see those people changing, they are hesitant to go first. And so this makes highly connected influencers into, you know, in some cases, a kind of roadblock. And you see that most of the successful initiatives for social change, this includes novel technologies like Twitter and Facebook, but also includes social movements like Black Lives Matter, Arab Spring and the Civil Rights Movement, grew from clusters of people in the network periphery who kind of grew a critical mass, also they had enough support that they went up tipping the center
他们等待着看粉丝们的想法。这可能违反直觉，但如果他们没有看到那些人做出改变，他们就会犹豫是否要先行一步。因此，这使得高度互联的影响者在某些情况下成为一种“路障”。你会发现，大多数成功的社会变革倡议，包括像 Twitter 和 Facebook 这样的新兴技术，也包括像“黑人的命也是命”、阿拉伯之春和民权运动这样的社会运动，都是从网络边缘的一群人中发展起来的，他们形成了一定的临界质量，并且获得了足够的支持，最终推动了中心
of the network and then it spread to everyone. But the origin story is always in the periphery not in the center. You can see the same thing in the rise of former President Donald Trump. When he first announced his candidacy for President back in 2015, most people in the Republican establishment laughed him off. Some media organizations declined to cover his campaign because they thought it was a joke. But Trump caught on with people in the periphery of the Republican party, and gradually his growing support from the margins overwhelmed the resistance of the establishment. The change did not start from the center and move out. It started from the outside and moved in.
网络，然后传播给所有人。但起源故事总是在边缘，而不是在中心。你可以在前总统唐纳德·特朗普的崛起中看到同样的事情。当他在 2015 年首次宣布竞选总统时，共和党建制派中的大多数人都嘲笑他。一些媒体机构拒绝报道他的竞选活动，因为他们认为这只是个笑话。但特朗普在共和党边缘人群中获得了支持，他从边缘地带获得的支持逐渐压倒了建制派的阻力。这种改变并非始于中心并向外扩散，而是始于外部并向内推进。
Damon says the exact same thing happens outside the political sphere. Take the example of something we talked about earlier, the rise of Twitter. Yeah, the origin story of Twitter is quite interesting because it is a story of peripheral growth, but it's also a story surprisingly of neighborhood growth, which when you think about internet technologies and social media, it's almost a truism that they would spread in the ether and not be constrained at all by local neighborhood geography. But in fact, Twitter grew initially in the San Francisco Bay Area, just through sort of friends and neighbors
达蒙说，政治领域之外也发生了完全相同的事情。以我们之前谈到的 Twitter 的崛起为例。是的，Twitter 的起源故事非常有趣，因为它是一个关于边缘增长的故事，但令人惊讶的是，它也是一个关于邻里增长的故事。当你想到互联网技术和社交媒体时，它们会在以太中传播，完全不受当地地理位置的限制，这几乎是一个公理。但事实上，Twitter 最初是在旧金山湾区发展起来的，仅仅是通过朋友和邻居
adopting from each other. And so that's sort of the strong tie, complex contagion story, but it gets more interesting. Because what ultimately happens is that there is an earthquake one day. And all of a sudden, it's not a big earthquake for the Bay Area, but still it's an earthquake.
之间的相互采纳。所以这是一种强关系、复杂传染的故事，但它变得更有趣了。因为最终发生的事情是，有一天发生了一场地震。突然之间，这对湾区来说不是一场大地震，但仍然是一场地震。
And Twitter became very, very useful instantly because people could coordinate with one another to figure out where shocks and after shocks were hitting, what their expectations were for what to do, and where family members were and how they were handling it. And so the sort of network really kind of galvanized. And then what happened that's pretty striking, I think the most surprising is that Twitter,
Twitter 瞬间变得非常非常有用，因为人们可以相互协调，弄清楚震源和余震在哪里，他们对该做什么的期望是什么，家人在哪里，以及他们是如何应对的。于是，这种网络真的被激活了。然后发生了一件非常引人注目的事情，我认为最令人惊讶的是，Twitter，
once they caught hold in San Francisco, didn't jump to LA or Chicago or New York. It actually started to spread across the countryside of California. It started to spread kind of south to San Jose and sort of north to Marin and to sort of slowly east to other parts of the sort of Bay Area and surrounding communities. And what you saw was that like as Twitter grew, it was in spreading viral through networks online. It was spreading spatially through neighborhoods.
一旦在旧金山站稳脚跟，并没有跳跃到洛杉矶、芝加哥或纽约。它实际上开始在加州的乡村地区传播。它开始向南传播到圣何塞，向北传播到马林，并缓慢地向东传播到湾区的其他地区和周边社区。你所看到的是，随着 Twitter 的增长，它不仅在网络上通过病毒式传播，还在空间上通过邻里关系传播。
And then something really unexpected happened, which is that as it filled out around the Bay Area, then Twitter showed up, again, not in New York or LA, but it showed up in Cambridge, Massachusetts. And that's where it sort of next took hold. And the reason is because a lot of people who live in San Francisco and Cambridge went to school together. They went to college, they studied technology, and they work in these different sectors, either along Route 28, 128 in Boston, which is a major technology area, or along, you know, in Silicon Valley. And so these two areas wind up being like highly connected socially with lots of reinforcing ties across them, and essentially form a network that's
然后发生了一件非常意想不到的事情，那就是当它在湾区周围填补空白时，Twitter 再次出现，不是在纽约或洛杉矶，而是在马萨诸塞州的剑桥。这就是它接下来站稳脚跟的地方。原因在于，许多住在旧金山和剑桥的人曾一起上学。他们上大学，学习技术，并在这些不同的部门工作，要么是在波士顿的 128 号公路沿线，这是一个主要的技术区，要么是在硅谷。因此，这两个地区最终在社交上高度互联，有着大量的强化联系，本质上形成了一个网络，
like a fishing net going from one part of the country across them. And essentially form a network that's like a fishing net going from one part of the country to another. And then once it landed in Cambridge, it spread out again, locally in Boston, around the Boston area. And then when it sort of amplified and took off and jumped from Cambridge, Massachusetts to Seattle,
就像一张从国家一部分延伸到另一部分的渔网。本质上形成了一个网络，就像一张从国家一部分延伸到另一部分的渔网。一旦它在剑桥落地，它就再次在当地传播，在波士顿周围。然后当它放大并起飞，从马萨诸塞州的剑桥跳跃到西雅图时，
which is another high tech hub, or people were connected to the people and so forth, and sort of gained traction in more and more cities, then ultimately it reached a tipping point around January 2009. And once it hit that tipping point, it just took off with hyper-extrapenational growth month after month. It went from 8 million to 20 million to 28 million very, very quickly. And that's the point at which Oprah adopted was during that period of massive growth. And even after that period, it continued to grow, but didn't grow as fast. That was the window for Twitter's major explosion. So Oprah is at the tail end of that process, not at the beginning. It's almost as if to get the celebrity endorsed,
那是另一个高科技中心，或者人们与那里的人有联系等等，并在越来越多的城市获得了牵引力，最终在 2009 年 1 月左右达到了临界点。一旦达到那个临界点，它就以月复一月的超指数增长起飞了。它非常非常快地从 800 万增长到 2000 万，再到 2800 万。这就是奥普拉采纳它的时间点，是在那个大规模增长的时期。即使在那之后，它继续增长，但没有那么快。那是 Twitter 主要爆发的窗口期。所以奥普拉是在那个过程的末尾，而不是在开始。这几乎就像是为了获得名人的背书，
the celebrity endorsed us coming on board, not in order to spur the avalanche, but because the avalanche is actually already gathered momentum. in some ways the celebrity influencer is very often surfing the avalanche that's already formed, not the one who's actually generating it. That's what I'm hearing from you. Yeah, and I think that's an important way to think about social change more generally. It makes sense that someone at the center of the network with lots and lots of connections and lots of reputational skin in the game, right? High stakes for the reputation is going to wait until something gains enough traction in the periphery of the network that there's a substantial critical mass that convinces them that this is actually a real thing that they should invest in as
名人的背书是后来加入的，不是为了刺激雪崩，而是因为雪崩实际上已经聚集了动力。在某种程度上，名人影响者往往是在冲浪已经形成的雪崩，而不是真正产生雪崩的人。这就是我从你那里听到的。是的，我认为这是思考社会变革的一个重要方式。对于一个在网络中心拥有大量联系和大量声誉风险的人来说，这很有意义，对吧？声誉风险很高，他们会等到某件事在网络边缘获得足够的牵引力，形成实质性的临界质量，让他们相信这是一件真正值得投资的事情，
well. And so that it makes sense that the costs for someone who's highly connected are higher in some way, so they wait longer, whereas the people in the periphery are sort of more easily excited and engaged by these sorts of ideas that are, you know, contentious or novel or different. And it's one of the reasons why social change almost always originates in the periphery of the network. How does this idea that change starts at the periphery apply to the rise of one of the largest social movements in recent years? Black Lives Matter. In 2020, the movement spread rapidly after George Floyd was pinned down and killed by Minneapolis police. The street has been breaking out in Philadelphia,
也是如此。因此，对于高度互联的人来说，成本在某种程度上更高，所以他们等待的时间更长，而边缘的人更容易被这些有争议的、新颖的或不同的想法所激发和吸引。这就是为什么社会变革几乎总是起源于网络边缘的原因之一。这种变革始于边缘的观点如何应用于近年来最大的社会运动之一？“黑人的命也是命”。2020 年，在乔治·弗洛伊德被明尼阿波利斯警察按倒并杀害后，这场运动迅速蔓延。街道在费城爆发，
Washington, D.C., Atlanta, and Oakland, California. As outraged spreads over the killing of George Floyd and the U.S., protesters have taken to the streets around the world. In Brazil, demonstrators have been raising their voices against the killing of black people mainly in poor neighborhoods. Demonstrations are continuing this weekend with protests held in East Asia and large crowds expected in European cities. I think the tragic death of George Floyd is one of the moments that I think our generation
华盛顿特区、亚特兰大和加利福尼亚州奥克兰。随着对乔治·弗洛伊德在美国被杀的愤怒蔓延，抗议者走上了世界各地的街头。在巴西，示威者一直在为黑人被杀而发声，主要是在贫困社区。示威活动在这个周末继续进行，东亚举行了抗议活动，预计欧洲城市也会有大量人群参加。我认为乔治·弗洛伊德的悲惨死亡是我们这一代人
will never forget. But what's interesting and I think what's most important for understanding Black Lives Matter is that people often explain that process by saying, well, there was a viral video of a white police officer killing George Floyd and that's what set off this sort of public outrage. But Damon reminds us that six years earlier, another video, every bit is disturbing, also made headlines. It showed the death of Eric Garner, a 43-year-old black man, at the hands of a white police officer
永远不会忘记的时刻之一。但有趣的是，我认为对于理解“黑人的命也是命”最重要的是，人们经常通过说“好吧，有一个白人警察杀害乔治·弗洛伊德的病毒式视频，这就是引发这种公众愤怒的原因”来解释这个过程。但达蒙提醒我们，六年前，另一个同样令人不安的视频也上了头条。它显示了 43 岁的黑人男子埃里克·加纳在白人警察手中死亡，
in New York City. When that video became public, thousands of people expressed their outrage on social media. And the term Black Lives Matter that hashtag was used about 600 times, but no major social change, and certainly nothing on a global scale emerged. The real change for Black Lives Matter when it became a movement that galvanized not just the nation, but also the world, was in August 2014. Michael Brown was killed in Ferguson, Missouri. On the streets of Ferguson, Missouri, outrage and anger.
在纽约市。当那个视频公开时，成千上万的人在社交媒体上表达了他们的愤怒。术语“黑人的命也是命”这个标签被使用了大约 600 次，但没有出现重大的社会变革，当然也没有出现全球规模的变革。“黑人的命也是命”真正的转折点，当它成为一场不仅激励了全国，而且激励了世界的运动时，是在 2014 年 8 月。迈克尔·布朗在密苏里州弗格森被杀。在弗格森的街头，愤怒和不满。
Protesters of different ages and races demanding answers in the shooting death of 18-year-old Michael Brown at the hands of a policeman. And the important thing to understand about what happened to make Black Lives Matter such a powerful movement is that the networks of people talking about this topic were really quite disconnected prior to Ferguson. There were communities of Black activists, there were communities of white liberals, communities
不同年龄和种族的抗议者要求对 18 岁的迈克尔·布朗在警察手中被枪杀一事给出答案。要理解是什么让“黑人的命也是命”成为如此强大的运动，重要的一点是，在弗格森事件之前，谈论这个话题的人的网络实际上是相当脱节的。有黑人活动家社区，有白人自由派社区，
of Black youth, communities of celebrities, communities of international media and white US media. And all of them were talking about these topics, communities of, you know, international media and white US media. And all of them were talking about these topics, but internally, basically a series of different bubbles. And then what wound up happening over the course of the several days or the week that, you know, the protest erupted in Ferguson is that the people who really got involved in social media and who really took over the conversation were regular citizens, just college student in the street.
黑人青年社区，名人社区，国际媒体和美国白人媒体社区。他们都在谈论这些话题，国际媒体和美国白人媒体社区。他们都在谈论这些话题，但在内部，基本上是一系列不同的泡沫。然后，在弗格森抗议爆发的那几天或一周里，真正参与社交媒体并真正接管对话的人是普通公民，只是街上的大学生。
Just this for you and me, just this for my proud. Posting notifications about what was happening in the police escalation and other citizens chiming in, talking about ways in which we could interpret, you know, the news that was reporting on this because at the beginning, the conversation that was happening on social media through a news site, like CNN, referred to the initial protests as, you know, a mob that was protesting the alleged shooting of a man. And immediately, just members of the community, regular people started responding to these tweets and engaging directly with mainstream media, saying, why mob? Why not, you know, citizens? or why not, you know, community members,
只是为了你和我，只是为了我的骄傲。发布关于警察升级中发生了什么的通知，其他公民也加入进来，讨论我们可以如何解读报道这一新闻的方式，因为起初，通过像 CNN 这样的新闻网站在社交媒体上进行的对话，将最初的抗议活动称为“抗议一名男子被指控枪击的暴徒”。社区成员、普通人立即开始回应这些推文，并直接与主流媒体互动，说为什么是暴徒？为什么不是公民？或者为什么不是社区成员，
and he had just graduated from high school, you know, he wasn't a man, and the alleged shooting was an actual shooting. And so this conversation had never really taken place before, and as media showed up and started engaging online, something really interesting happened in Ferguson, which is that activist groups started interacting directly with, you know, mainstream white media, and then black youth who weren't really engaged happened in Ferguson, which is that activist groups started interacting directly with mainstream
他刚从高中毕业，他不是一个男人，所谓的枪击事件是一次实际的枪击事件。所以这种对话以前从未真正发生过，随着媒体出现并开始在线互动，弗格森发生了一件非常有趣的事情，那就是活动家团体开始直接与主流白人媒体互动，然后是没有真正参与的黑人青年，弗格森发生了什么，那就是活动家团体开始直接与主流
white media. And then black youth, who weren't really engaged in these activist conversations, started becoming engaged as well, along with the regular citizens who were on the street in Ferguson and other citizens from around the country. And so what wound up happening was that these bridges between these different social groups became wider. The relationships became thicker and people started to kind of influence each other. And one of the early victories
白人媒体互动。然后，没有真正参与这些活动家对话的黑人青年也开始参与进来，与街上的普通公民以及来自全国各地的其他公民一起。最终发生的事情是，这些不同社会群体之间的桥梁变得更宽了。关系变得更紧密了，人们开始相互影响。而早期的胜利之一
that didn't get a lot of attention at the time, but it was really important for the growth of Black Lives Matter was that by the end of that first week, mainstream media was reporting on those protests differently. They were referring to Michael Brown as someone who just graduated high school. They were talking about it as a shooting and they were talking about it as community members
当时并没有引起太多关注，但对于“黑人的命也是命”的增长非常重要，那就是在第一周结束时，主流媒体对这些抗议活动的报道方式不同了。他们称迈克尔·布朗为刚从高中毕业的人。他们谈论这是一起枪击事件，他们谈论这是社区成员
and citizens protesting rather than a mob. At the prosecutor's office, about 150 people called for justice for Michael Brown, the unarmed 18-year-old killed by police. And so all of a sudden hashtag Black Lives Matter, which had only been used 600 times prior to Ferguson, was used over a million times. And it really sort of ballooned into something where all these different communities were coordinated on a way of talking and a way of thinking, but identified police violence and civil owned fractions as something that united all these different deaths.
和公民在抗议，而不是暴徒。在检察官办公室，大约 150 人呼吁为迈克尔·布朗伸张正义，这名被警察杀害的 18 岁手无寸铁的少年。于是，在弗格森之前只被使用过 600 次的“黑人的命也是命”标签，突然被使用了超过一百万次。它真的膨胀成了一种所有这些不同社区都在协调一种谈话方式和思考方式的东西，但将警察暴力和民事违规行为确定为团结所有这些不同死亡事件的东西。
All of a sudden, New York City had something specific in common with Ferguson Missouri. And then in the months after that, others, Central Blond and Tamir Rice, those deaths, instead of being isolated incidents, became unified under a core message of the Black Lives Matter movement and everyone understood it that way. And this really changed the national conversation. All of a sudden, by 2019, the hashtag Black Lives Matter was used 17,000 times a day. It just became this sort of consistent way
突然之间，纽约市与密苏里州弗格森有了某种具体的共同点。在那之后的几个月里，其他人，桑德拉·布兰德和塔米尔·赖斯，那些死亡事件，不再是孤立的事件，而是统一在“黑人的命也是命”运动的核心信息之下，每个人都以那种方式理解它。这确实改变了全国的对话。突然之间，到 2019 年，“黑人的命也是命”标签每天被使用 17,000 次。它变成了这种一致的方式，
that people across different groups were talking about it. And that actually set the stage for what happened in 2020. What do you think it is that when we hear about these incidents and we look at the Black Lives Matter movement, or we hear about the Rosa Park story and we see the civil rights movement. What do you think prompts us to want the simple story that basically says, you know, Rosa
不同群体的人都在谈论它。这实际上为 2020 年发生的事情奠定了基础。你认为当我们听到这些事件并审视“黑人的命也是命”运动，或者听到罗莎·帕克斯的故事并看到民权运动时，是什么促使我们想要那个简单的故事，基本上说，你知道，罗莎·帕克斯
Park's refused to give our proceed in the bus and that triggered the civil rights movement or George Floyd was killed and that triggered the Black Lives Matter movement. Instead of seeing the very complex social networks that had to be created in order in some ways for these flashpoints to have the effects that they did. The way of thinking that's familiar to us is thinking about spreading as a viral process or as an epidemic process, largely because we understand it so well.
拒绝在公交车上让座，这引发了民权运动，或者乔治·弗洛伊德被杀，这引发了“黑人的命也是命”运动。而不是看到为了让这些闪光点产生它们所具有的效果，必须创造的非常复杂的社交网络。我们熟悉的思维方式是将传播视为一种病毒过程或流行病过程，主要是因为我们非常了解它。
There's been just a century of science explaining how contagion happens and explaining what we can expect as a flu spreads around the world. And so we use those as metaphors for interpreting things that we don't understand. And I think that's entirely reasonable. One of the exciting things about the science of sociology is that it's really only in the last two decades
已经有一个世纪的科学解释了传染是如何发生的，并解释了当流感在全球传播时我们可以期待什么。因此，我们使用这些作为隐喻来解释我们不理解的事情。我认为这完全合理。社会学科学令人兴奋的事情之一是，实际上只有在过去的二十年里，
that we've been able to do experiments or analyze large-scale data in real time. And that's what social media has given us is a way of sort of observing these processes in real time and And that's what social media is given us is a way of sort of observing these processes in real time and to see how they unfold and really show that the same kinds of theories that we can use to develop new models and new policies are the same kinds of theories that really explain changes in the world around us like Black Lives Matter. The idea that a group of people on the periphery can change entire societies is powerful.
我们才能够实时进行实验或分析大规模数据。这就是社交媒体给我们的东西，一种实时观察这些过程的方式，并看到它们如何展开，并真正表明我们可以用来开发新模型和新政策的相同理论，也是真正解释我们周围世界变化（如“黑人的命也是命”）的相同理论。边缘的一群人可以改变整个社会的想法是强大的。
It's like the image of a rolling snowball that eventually produces an avalanche. So how many people do you initially need to get that snowball rolling? How small can that committed minority be to drive change? The answer will surprise you. That's after the break. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It happens all the time.
这就像一个滚雪球的形象，最终产生了一场雪崩。那么你最初需要多少人才能让那个雪球滚动起来？那个坚定的少数派可以有多小来推动变革？答案会让你大吃一惊。休息之后再回来。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这种情况一直都在发生。
A company, an idea, or a social movement comes out of seemingly nowhere and becomes wildly popular. Sometimes even the people with the idea don't fully understand what happened. They have been laboring for decades in obscurity before suddenly striking it big. Sociologist Damon Santola has explored how such revolutions unfold. In his book, Change, he offers a roadmap for policymakers, entrepreneurs, and change agents on how to deploy social networks to bring about change.
一家公司、一个想法或一场社会运动似乎凭空出现，并变得非常流行。有时即使是提出这个想法的人也不完全理解发生了什么。他们在默默无闻中奋斗了几十年，然后突然大获成功。社会学家达蒙·桑托拉探索了这种革命是如何展开的。在他的书《变革》中，他为政策制定者、企业家和变革推动者提供了一份关于如何部署社交网络以带来变革的路线图。
They mean we've looked at different models of how things spread at a very simple level of virus can spread through a network of casual acquaintances, what sociologists might call weak ties. Some ideas spread because a celebrity makes an announcement, but merely getting information to spread far and wide does not always translate to action. If changing behavior is your goal, it often makes more sense to generate change in small groups on the periphery and slowly get the movement to expand from there. You've run experiments where
达蒙，我们研究了事物如何传播的不同模型，在非常简单的层面上，病毒可以通过偶然相识的网络传播，社会学家称之为“弱关系”。一些想法因为名人的宣布而传播，但仅仅让信息传播得广并不总是转化为行动。如果改变行为是你的目标，那么在边缘的小群体中产生变革并缓慢地让运动从那里扩展通常更有意义。你做过实验，
you test whether a committed small minority can change the behavior of people in a group. Do you find that they can and how small can this committed minority be to actually have an impact? Instead of we ran examin different sizes of committed minorities or groups who would try to advance a social change and we looked at groups from 17% through 25% up to 30% to see what fraction of a population would be required to change everyone else's mind. And what we found was a really clear cutoff at 25%. Pretty much every group below 25%, whether that was 17% or 20% or 21%, had almost no
你测试了一个坚定的少数派是否可以改变群体中人们的行为。你发现他们可以吗？这个坚定的少数派要多小才能真正产生影响？我们测试了不同规模的坚定少数派或试图推动社会变革的群体，我们观察了从 17% 到 25% 再到 30% 的群体，看看需要人口的多少比例才能改变其他所有人的想法。我们发现了一个非常清晰的 25% 的临界点。几乎所有低于 25% 的群体，无论是 17%、20% 还是 21%，几乎都没有
impact on the behavior of the rest of the group. But as soon as the committed minority or the activist reached 25%, everyone else in the group changed their behavior to do with the committed minority was doing. And this worked, of course, for 28% and for 29% and for 30%. And so this provides kind of a really clear cutoff point when we can say even though a group that was at 22% seems hopeless, it seems like they're not making much impact, which is a little bit more support they can actually have an enormous impact on whatever else is doing. So the fascinating thing is when we think about
对群体中其他人的行为产生影响。但一旦坚定的少数派或活动家达到 25%，群体中的其他人就会改变他们的行为，去做坚定的少数派正在做的事情。当然，这对于 28%、29% 和 30% 也适用。因此，这提供了一个非常清晰的临界点，我们可以说，即使一个处于 22% 的群体看起来毫无希望，看起来他们没有产生多大影响，但只要多一点支持，他们实际上就可以对其他人正在做的事情产生巨大的影响。所以令人着迷的是，当我们思考
these tipping points, it might actually explain why it is a movement might be struggling in obscurity for a long time, and then it reaches this tipping point and suddenly something changes and something that seemed impossible seems like it's inevitable. Yeah, it really answers the puzzle, why is social change so abrupt? Because it seems intuitive to think, well, you know, something gains traction
这些临界点时，它可能实际上解释了为什么一场运动可能会在默默无闻中挣扎很长时间，然后它达到了这个临界点，突然之间发生了变化，看起来不可能的事情似乎变得不可避免了。是的，它确实回答了这个谜题，为什么社会变革如此突然？因为认为某件事获得牵引力并应该以增量方式增加似乎很直观。所以它会变得越来越受欢迎，然后最终它就会成功。但我们在社会变革中并没有真正看到这一点。我们基本上看到的是一个大多数人没有意识到的隐藏过程。有一个边缘运动，有一个似乎没有产生多大影响的活动家团体。然后几乎突然之间，每个人都开始认真对待这个想法。2014 年，人们被询问他们的意见，他们不支持抗议。
and it should sort of increase incrementally. So it'll get more and more and more popular and then eventually it won't be doing it. But we don't really see that with social change. We see basically that there's a hidden process that most people are not aware of. There's a fringe movement, there's an activist group that seems not to be having much impact. And then almost all of a sudden, everyone sort of takes this idea seriously. In 2014, people were pulled about their opinions, and they didn't support the protest.
他们认为黑人社区的治安确实没有问题。然后在 2020 年乔治·弗洛伊德事件之后，绝大多数美国人，无论是共和党人还是民主党人，都表示他们认为“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动是正当的，黑人社区的治安确实存在问题。这是一个巨大的变化，
And they thought that there was really no problem of policing in black communities. And then after George Floyd in 2020, the vast majority of Americans, both Republicans and Democrats, said that they thought that the black guys matter protests were justified, and there was a problem with policing in black communities. And that's an enormous change
在短短六年内，公众舆论和公众意识发生了变化。你可以在世界各地看到社会网络力量的许多其他例子。在一项研究中，劳里·比曼的研究分析了非洲国家马拉维的一次干预。政府想要推广一种新的耕作技术。研究发现，传播这个想法最有效的方法是将说服
in sort of public opinion, public consciousness in just six years. You can see many other examples around the world of the power of social networks. In one study, the research on Laurie Beaman analyzed an intervention in the African country of Malawi. The government wanted to spread use of a new farming technique. The research has found the most effective way to spread the idea was to concentrate persuasion
努力集中在少数几个村庄，并让这个想法站稳脚跟。随着这些地区开始看到成功，其他村庄开始效仿他们，变革有机地传播开来。我们可以很容易地利用这个洞察力进行各种变革。如果我是市政府，我想让更多的人在屋顶上安装太阳能电池板，我可能会想说，好吧，我有一笔拨款可以给 300 户家庭提供太阳能电池板，我会尽可能广泛地分配我的资金。然而，更好的策略可能是将我的电池板集中在几条街道的房子上。
efforts on a small number of villages and get the idea to take hold. As those areas began to see success, other villages started to copy them and the change spread organically. We could easily capitalize on this insight for all kinds of change. If I'm a city government and I want to get more people to install solar panels on their roofs, I might be tempted to say, alright, I have a grant that can give out solar panels to 300 houses, I'm going to spread my money as widely as possible. The better strategy, however, might be to concentrate my panels on houses on a few streets.
目标是让邻居看到正在发生的事情，并希望自己也安装太阳能电池板。是的，我认为关于太阳能电池板采纳的最引人注目的结果之一是它非常本地化。这确实是一种邻里效应。政府，特别是在欧洲，在激励人们采纳太阳能电池板以及激励公司制造太阳能电池板并使其可用方面做得非常出色。
The goal is to get neighbors to see what's happening and want to get solar panels of their own. Yeah, I think that one of the most striking of results about solar panel adoption is that it's so incredibly localized. It's really a neighborhood effect. And governments, particularly in Europe, have done an excellent job of incentivizing people to adopt solar panels and incentivizing companies to build solar panels and make them available.
但他们发现这不足以真正产生临界点或规范的改变。在某种意义上，这是临界点的关键问题。每个人都在等待别人先行一步。所以德国政府做的一件非常聪明的事情是，他们开始针对社区，安装并激励房主在特定社区内安装太阳能电池板。这改变了这些社区内的社会规范，并
But they found that that wasn't sufficient to actually generate a tipping point or a change in the norms. In some sense, that's the crucial issue with tipping points. Everyone's waiting for everyone else to go first. So one thing that the German government did that was so clever is they started targeting neighborhoods and installing incentivizing homeowners to just install within certain neighborhoods solar panels on their homes. And this shifted the social norms within those communities and
对邻居产生了一种社会压力，让他们意识到这在他们的社区中现在是正常的。然后他们自愿去采纳了太阳能电池板。这个过程中最引人注目的部分是，它从一个社区蔓延到另一个社区，从一个邻里蔓延到另一个邻里，最终成为整个德国的主导社会规范，每个人都被期望在他们的房子上安装这些太阳能电池板。我们在英国、日本，甚至加利福尼亚和康涅狄格州的某些社区也看到了类似的效果。
created kind of a social pressure on the neighbors to realize that this was actually normal in their community now. And then they voluntarily went and adopted solar panels. And the most remarkable part about this process is that it spilled over from community to community and neighborhood to neighborhood and wound up becoming the dominant social norm throughout Germany that everyone was expected to have these solar panels on their homes. And we've seen similar effects in Britain, similar effects in Japan, even in certain neighborhoods in California and Connecticut.
因此，就房主对他们应该做什么的期望而言，邻里效应非常强大，并且实际上影响了国家规模上对太阳能电池板等事物的采纳。现在，即使有些人不理解这些关于什么驱动变革的教训，也有其他人似乎非常理解这些教训。一些威权政权正在巧妙地利用这些想法，不是为了支持变革，而是为了压制变革。你能告诉我关于中国的“五毛党”吗？是的，我认为这是社会科学中比较重要的事情之一。社会学现在正接近这一点，我们可以以足够的
And so the sort of neighborhood effects in terms of homeowners expectations about what they shouldn't be doing are very powerful and actually impact at a national scale adoption of something like solar panels. Now even as there are people who don't understand these lessons about what drive change, there are others who seem to understand these lessons very well. Some authoritarian regimes are cleverly using these ideas not to support change, but to suppress change. Can you tell me about China's 50 cent party? Yeah, and I think this is one of the sort of more important things about social science. Sociologies now approaching this point where we can understand with enough
严谨和洞察力理解是什么支配了这些变革过程，我们也必须担心这对可能利用这些想法的政府意味着什么。中国正是这样做的。他们做了一些既聪明又具有破坏性的事情，那就是当中国社交媒体上的人们，每当发生起义时，或者发生抗议事件时，你可能会认为政府会利用社交媒体，每当发生起义或抗议事件时，你可能会认为政府会利用社交媒体来宣传其自己的虚假新闻或关于实际发生了什么的虚假信息。但相反，他们设计了一种极其不同的策略，本质上是战略性的
rigor and insight what governs these kinds of change processes that we also have to worry about what the implications are for governments who might use these ideas. And China has done exactly that. They've done something that is clever but also destructive, which is when people on social media in China, whenever an uprising takes place, so our protest event takes place, you would think that the government would use social media in China, whenever an uprising takes place or a protest event takes place, you would think that the government would use social media to promote its own sort of fake news or false information about what was actually happening. But instead they devised an incredibly different strategy, which was essentially strategic
非相关性。所以他们会有伪装成真实的人、作为社交媒体社区成员的代理人。当人们开始谈论抗议事件或关于政府或其政策的某种问题时，这些社交媒体代理人，被称为“五毛党”，因为他们每条被支付五毛钱，他们开始谈论当地的游行，或者他们会开始谈论某种共产主义原则。
non-sequitors. So they would have agents who were masquerading as real people as members of the social media community. And as people started talking about a protest event or about some sort of problem with So they would have agents who were masquerading as real people as members of the social media community. And as people started talking about a protest event or about some sort of problem with the government or its policy, these social media agents, which were called the 50 cent party because they were paid 50 cents in Chinese Joe, they started talking about a local parade or they would start talking about some principle of communist doctrine.
这个想法是，如果你有足够多的人在相互交谈，它基本上会创造一个临界质量，让其他谈论合法抗议问题或合法不满的人觉得他们的谈话不再相关了，因为相关的是对当地游行或烟花表演的庆祝。因此，它最终改变了人们对我们
And the idea was if you have enough of these people talking to each other, it basically creates a critical mass where the other people talking about legitimate protest issues or legitimate grievances feel like their conversation isn't relevant anymore, which relevant is this celebration of a local parade or a fireworks display. And so it winds up changing the expectations of what we
在社交媒体上能谈论什么和不能谈论什么的期望，仅仅是因为创造了一个正在做与其他人不同事情的人的临界质量。这对于破坏中国社交媒体上的活动家努力非常有效。这是一种在不真正烧书或在 20 世纪中叶极权政权使用的那种方式上审查人们的情况下，实际上压制异议的非凡方式。是的，我在书中谈论它的方式是，他们与其说是在审查煽动性书籍，不如说是在用通俗小说的吸引力淹没市场。
can and can't talk about on social media just by virtue of creating a critical mass of people who are doing something different than other people were doing. And it's been incredibly effective for derailing activists efforts on Chinese social media. It's sort of a remarkable way of actually suppressing descent without actually you know, burning books or basically actually censoring people in sort of the ways that totalitarian regimes used to do in the middle part of the 20th century. Yeah, the way I talk about it in the book is they're not so much censoring seditious books as much as flooding the market with the appeal of pulp fiction.
当我退后一步思考这项广泛的工作时，达蒙，在非社会学家思考社交网络的程度上，我认为我们倾向于将它们视为管道。所以这些是向我们传递信息的管道。我从 Twitter 上的那群人那里获取信息。我从 Facebook 上的那群人那里获取信息。你在很多方面说，这是思考社交网络力量的错误方式。它们不是管道，而是其他东西。
As I step back and I think about this broad work, Damon, to the extent that non-sociologists think about social networks, I think we tend to think of them as pipes. So these are sort of pipes that deliver us information. I get information from this set of people on Twitter. I get information from that set of people on Facebook. You're saying in many ways that that's the wrong way to think about the power of social networks. They're not pipes, but something else.
管道隐喻确实来自疾病传播，也就是说，如果我坐在机场你旁边，而你感染了冠状病毒，现在我感染了冠状病毒，这个过程没有什么深刻的、人际的或有意义的。它真的只是传播。当我们思考那个传播过程，并思考像高度互联的影响者这样的事情时，它只是一个拥有大量管道通向社会其他部分的人，他们可以将任何内容传播给那些人，等等。但当我们观察新闻传播等事物时，它并不那么简单。人们过滤这些想法或新科学信息的网络实际上在很大程度上决定了你对信息的接受程度，无论你是否相信它，无论你是否拒绝它，或者你是否只是以与最初意图非常
The pipe metaphor really comes from disease transmission, which is to say, if I sit next to you in an airport and you're infected with a coronavirus, now I get the coronavirus, there's nothing should have, you know, deep or interpersonal or meaningful about that process. It's really just a transmission. And when we think about that transmission process and we think about things like highly connected influence or it's just a person with lots and lots of pipes going out to other parts of society and they can spread whatever content to those people and so on and so forth. But when we look at things like the spread of news, it's not so simple. The networks through which people filter these ideas or new scientific information are actually doing a lot of work to determine how receptive you are to the information whether you believe it whether you rejected or whether you just interpret it very
不同的方式来解读它。因此，这就是社交网络作为棱镜的方式，通过我们与之互动的人来折射和塑造我们持有的信念。因此，我们在解决社会问题方面思考的事情之一是，我们如何塑造人们拥有的互动，或者也许以更有效的方式构建它们。思考，你知道，在解决社会问题方面，是我们如何塑造人们拥有的互动，或者也许以更有效的方式构建它们。你可以做的一件事是采取一个集中的回声室，使网络更加平等。但我们发现，这对于改变社区中人们的实际信念非常有效。事实上，当你采取类似的民主党人和共和党人群体
differently than was originally intended. And so this is the way in which social networks act as prisms that refract in shape the beliefs that we hold by virtue of the people that we interact with. And so one of the things that we think about in terms of solving social problems is how we can shape the interactions people have or maybe structure them in ways that are more productive. think about, you know, in terms of, you know, solving social problems, is how we can shape the interactions people have or maybe structure them in ways that are more productive. One thing you can do is to take a centralized echo chamber and make the networks more egalitarian. But we've found is that this is unbelievably effective for changing the actual beliefs of people in a community. In fact, when you take similar groups of Democrats and Republicans
在移民、气候变化或枪支管制等问题上高度两极分化，并让他们在更像渔网的网络中互动时。来自这些社区边缘的观点和想法实际上可以获得牵引力并得到加强。最终发生的事情是，两个社区独立地向对方移动，你最终产生了一种想法的和解，
who are highly polarized on issues like immigration or climate change or gun control, and you let them interact within networks that are more like fishing nets. Opinions and ideas from the periphery of those communities can actually gain traction and be reinforced. And what winds up happening is that both communities independently move toward each other, and you wind up generating a kind of reconciliation of ideas,
仅仅是因为好的想法往往在社交网络的边缘，但当它们被一个权力巨大的中心影响者阻挡时，它们将无法流行或产生任何影响。达蒙·桑托拉是《变革》的作者，这是一本关于社会运动和创业成功的书。他是宾夕法尼亚大学的社会学家。达蒙，感谢你今天加入我的《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，这是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里吉特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、
just by virtue of the fact that good ideas are often in the periphery of the social network, but they wouldn't have been able to catch on or have any influence when they were being blocked by a highly powerful central influencer. Daemon Centella is the author of Change, a book about social movements and entrepreneurial success. He's a sociologist at the University of Pennsylvania. Daemon, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's my pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz,
奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的英雄歌曲是《图书馆杂志》。这是一份美国各地的图书馆员阅读的出版物。几个月前，《图书馆杂志》邀请我参加他们的年度会议，谈论我的新书《有用的错觉》。我的小组成员之一是达蒙·桑托拉。
Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run song Hero Today is the Library Journal. It's a publication read by librarians around the United States. Some months ago, the Library Journal invited me to their annual conference to talk about my new book, Useful Delusions. One of my fellow panelists was Damon Centola.
我非常喜欢听他的想法，以至于我在不久之后联系了他，并邀请他来到《隐藏的大脑》。图书馆员在《隐藏的大脑》中占有特殊的地位。书籍是我们节目的命脉。我感谢《图书馆杂志》将我介绍给达蒙·桑托拉的工作，并感谢该组织为吸引人们对作家和想法的关注所做的所有其他工作。
I so enjoyed hearing about his ideas that I reached out to him shortly afterwards and asked him about coming on Hidden Brain. Librarians have a special place in our heart at Hidden Brain. Books are the lifeblood of our show. I'm grateful to the Library Journal for introducing me to Damon Centola's work, and for all the other work the organization does, to draw attention to writers and ideas.
我非常喜欢听他的想法，以至于在那之后不久我就联系了他，并邀请他参加《Hidden Brain》节目。图书馆员在我们的《Hidden Brain》节目中占有特殊的地位。书籍是我们节目的命脉。我很感谢《图书馆杂志》将达蒙·森托拉的作品介绍给我，也感谢该组织为吸引人们关注作家和思想所做的所有其他工作。
For more Hidden Brain, sign up for our weekly newsletter where we explore ideas related to this week's show and share other links. Sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. If you like today's show, please consider supporting us. Go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要了解更多Hidden Brain的内容，请订阅我们的每周通讯，我们将探讨与本周节目相关的主题并分享其他链接。请访问news.hiddenbrain.org进行订阅。如果您喜欢今天的节目，请考虑支持我们。请访问hiddenbrain.org并点击“支持”。我是Shankar Vedantam。下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。